right thank you thanks daniele and uh um
thank you to daniel and chris for giving
us the extra 30 minutes
maybe i shouldn't have mentioned it but
uh you know what it's gonna delay your
lunch bye
we're gonna finish early though um just
trying to prepare my slides and i really
couldn't find much to say so let's
okay so so so i'm gonna start with
attribute-based encryption
um for general circuits uh from lattices
um
and hotek will follow up with predicate
encryption we'll tell you what these
things are why these things are
important and how to construct them
and we're good we're really going to use
uh the much of the technology that uh
zwika and daniel presented to you um in
the last hour
um but you know in case you don't
remember in case you weren't in the talk
just feel free to speak up and ask ques
questions okay
all right let's start let me start with
an example this is from the work of
goyal pandey's high end waters uh to
motivate um
attribute-based encryption so imagine
that you have a user
let's say a user is a network switch
which
wants to store logs
logs of network data in a server
and you know these things are sensitive
typically uh so you encrypt uh
you know or you should encrypt these uh
this data
um put it all in the cloud um
that's all great right um uh but now
comes the
twist there are you know this data
doesn't just sit there
you know and wait until it gets
decrypted right i mean so
there are a bunch of users these are
sort of network administrators
people who are trying to find sort of
you know run sort of intrusion detection
algorithms
so on and so forth and these people want
access to certain parts of the data
right for example
the the girl at the top she wants to
access
all sort of encryptions of network logs
where the
ip is in a certain range um not the most
interesting but
ip is in a certain range and the size is
less than
let's say so many bytes right so this is
a characteristic of
the data packets that it wants to be
able to decrypt
um and so on and so forth so you could
imagine
that there are people who want to
decrypt certain you know network logs
belonging to a certain date and with a
certain size ip so on and so forth you
can just
you can imagine these access policies
that characterize which subset of the
data
each user is allowed to access okay so
that's uh that's what it is
so now how do you how do you solve this
question right how do you give give
these users
access to the right subset of the
encrypted data you could think of many
solutions
you could say well you know let the
users go to
at t and ask them for you know
these records att will check these these
records decrypt and uh
and give it to them or you know it
could be reasonable in fact it could be
reasonable in many uh sort of practical
situations
uh but for our purposes we don't want at
t to be online
and who wants all this decrypted data
the users want these things
so the bulk of the computation
right i mean in getting in accessing the
data and decrypting it
should be at the user's end but that's
what i want it to be
okay so the user should do all the job
the cloud should really be
sort of a bulletin board of encrypted
data
right and the user should just be able
to go and access
the right piece of information that's
what i want
so how do i do it well this is the
notion of attribute based
based encryption and that says the
following so when you encrypt
a cipher text don't just encrypt the
message just
you know in the plane instead encrypt it
together
with relevant attributes right i mean so
these are the
uh these are the sort of the attributes
that the users want to sort of index
over
right so in this example you encrypted
the network logs with
uh an ip a date size whatever
right i mean whatever is interesting in
that context
now let's go to the users each user has
a policy a policy is just a boolean
circuit
okay it says you know which attributes
you know which cipher text should i be
able to access right so the policy
acts on the set of attributes and it
says yes or no
if there is a cipher text encrypted
under attribute sex
which satisfy a certain policy this user
should be able to access it otherwise no
right very simple
okay so that's that's all very nice
what happens is that uh at the beginning
of time
each user goes to the the master the
person with the
actual secret key and requests for
a sub secret key a smaller secret key a
restricted secret key
that allows it to only decrypt those
cipher attacks
which it is you know permitted to
decrypt right which satisfy
the access policy right that's what
that's what i want
so each person gets a key and you can
see these keys are you know a little bit
different right uh
and each key lets you do a different
thing that's that's what it is
so what do i want so let's look at the
first user right
should she be able to access this uh
decrypt the ciphertext and access the
logs yes because you know the ip is in
the right range and the size is pretty
small
okay so given the secret key this
ciphertext
should be decryptable okay
so in other words given a ciphertext
encrypted with attributes x
and data m and the secret key for a
policy p
for circuit p you should be able to
recover m if and only if
the policy evaluated on the attributes
is true and true to confuse the hell out
of you
is going to be zero for me okay i mean
you know what's confusing to you is not
confusing to me and i prefer to
you know you know confuse you rather
than say something false okay so so
let's uh
let's stick with that zero is true zero
is true let's repeat the mantra a couple
of times
what's false anything not zero is false
okay that's a
zero good okay so that's what should
happen what should not happen
is that even if there are two users
with these policies right i mean these
policies sort of
partially satisfy the attributes or
rather the attributes partially satisfy
these policies so
here the size is certainly less than uh
if this
attributes are certainly less than 16
bytes but uh the date is not correct
here the ip is correct but the size is
not correct right so they kind of
partially satisfy these
the attributes partially satisfy these
policies and the point
is that even if these two guys come
together
they cannot mix and match their keys to
come up with
uh to decrypt this ciphertext okay
because neither of them individually
has the authority to decrypt the
ciphertext so put them together they
should still not be able to decrypt the
ciphertext
okay that's what i want in other words
this
and we say that even if you have a set
of secrets p1 for policies p1 up to pk
such that neither of them each pi
evaluated on x
is false
the secret keys for these pi's together
should not be able to decrypt the
ciphertext okay so this is called
collusion resistance
in our parlance okay so this is what i
want
this is one example uh you will see a
perhaps even better example in
hotex talk but let's let's move on
okay good so the question is really um
you know the high order bit here is uh
what happens to the attributes right i
mean the data is hidden
that's that's the point what happens to
the attributes attributes you can think
of it as metadata
right i mean these are just kind of
pieces of information that help you
decide
access or not access so you know you can
think
that uh you can think of two settings
one where the metadata is actually okay
to reveal that's called that is the
setting of attribute based encryption
where the attributes acts are public
public in the sense everyone knows it
right i mean it's
you can think about it as the cipher
text written together with the
attributes might as well
right and then the so the
a nicer notion in a sense of predicate
and functional encryption which hertek
will talk about
which hides even the metadata right that
says it's a stronger notion
um and uh hotek will tell you what that
is
so why should you care about
attribute-based encryption well there
might be settings where you don't care
about
hiding the metadata it is more efficient
and more importantly
it is a stepping stone to achieving
these stronger notions predicate
functional encryption
and perhaps even obfuscation this is
really the the baseline that uh that we
have to work with so we understand the
baseline and we
understand everything else okay so
this talk the first part of the talk i'm
going to tell you about attribute-based
encryption just
exclusively focus on attribute-based
encryption and i'll talk about this work
all these people you know
together with all these people um and uh
hotek will tell you about
the work on try to get interruptions
okay so such a good base encryption very
very nice primitive
as uh hopefully you're already convinced
um this
notion was first introduced by sahai and
waters and like i mentioned this work of
goyal pandey sahin waters and it was
inspired by early work on
things like identity based encryption
which you could think about as a special
case
of attribute based encryption fuzzy ib
so on and so forth
right and and and what they did
until about 2013 the sort of the
standard
in this in this regime in this in this
line of work
was uh an attribute based encryption for
policies for circuits that can be
written down as nc
one circuits logarithmic depth circuits
right i mean
so this is not all policies but it's a
pretty expressive class of policies
right and that was where things uh
that's the work of
goyal one day so and it was sort of
stuck there for
uh for a few years uh there were a lot
of works
surrounding this you know to get
adaptive security to improve the
efficiency so on and so forth but really
if you look at the class of policies
that you can support that's where we
were at
2013 uh there were a couple of works
one with uh sergey and uh and hotec
where we constructed the first abe
scheme for general circuits in other
words
you know hit me with your policy okay so
tell me what your policy is
i'm gonna give you uh you know show you
a way to generate keys
okay so um so that's one and
concurrently there was this work of
gentry hallelujah
and waters uh they had a completely
different construction
totally different based on multilinear
maps
okay good so so that's what that is and
in fact i could tell you about this work
this ab scheme but i'm not going to
i'm going to instead tell you about a
better ab scheme there was in a join in
a sort of follow-up work with dan and uh
craig and sergey and shy and uh
valeria and gil and uh let me take my
breath uh
and uh um okay so that's what uh that's
what the point is
and the reason i'm telling you this is
not because uh of anything else but
because it nicely builds on top of what
you've already seen
yes both of these are level
yes yes good great question so uh we'll
we'll get to that in a minute so the
question here is
are these abe schemes leveled in the
sense that can they support
circuits of any size and any depth or do
i have to place a bound on the depth
probably doesn't make i mean i don't
know if this makes sense to you right
now but if it doesn't parenthetical
comment
yes
good all right so uh so so we talked
about informally
what security means for abe schemes uh
let me be a little bit more formal
um so this is exactly like an encryption
scheme right i mean there's a public key
i'm going to call it mpk for master
publicly because
there is a master secret key it's friend
and then there are little secret keys so
i want to give it a distinguished name
so that's a master publicly the
adversary gets it he picks uh
two messages m0 and m1 which is exactly
like an indistinguishable
indistinguishability security game uh
together with the challenge
attribute x-star right so gives it to
the guy
uh the guy says well flip a coin encrypt
m sub b
give the cipher text back to the guy
right back to the
adversary the adversary's goal is to
guess which message
the challenger encrypted so that's
good but i haven't quite uh said what
else the adversary gets there is this
you know policy there's a secret key
what happened to that
well the adversary can also
request for secret keys for policies
that it comes up with it divides
these circuits right uh circuits p and
it asks for secret keys for these p
many times as many times as it wants
polynomially many times
and guess what it can do it before and
after so it's a bit like a cca2
type setting you can get many secret
keys and still
it should not be able to guess which
message was encrypted
right that's what i want right a bunch
of users each one having a secret key
for a certain policy
should not be able to come together and
decrypt it
but that's not good enough right because
sometimes they might be able to decrypt
if the if one of these policies actually
satisfied
this or rather this attribute satisfied
one of these policies
of course the functionality says that
you can decrypt
right so i have to sort of take much i
have to sort of define
i have to come up with a security
definition modulo that condition
the correctness condition which of
course you know this is what i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna say the adversary wins if he
guesses which message was encrypted
and none of these policies none of these
circuits that it came up with
you know satisfied the uh um
attribute so the attributes didn't
satisfy any of these circuits right so
that's that's that
one is false one is false
would it be considerable to have cca
security in this setup
yes i i think so yeah and uh
and uh i don't want to sort of bet my
pinky on it but uh
i think you can get it generically in a
sense because
we know that uh this result of canadian
levian cards says that you can take an
identity based encryption
system and construct a cca secure public
key encryption system from it
so this is a souped-up identity-based
encryption in a sense
so you can you can you can get cca also
yes i think so
good okay so this is security right uh
and uh like luka said that you could
augment
this with cca security we're not gonna
do that today
okay good all right so uh
in fact we are actually going to weaken
the security definition a little bit
uh we're going to talk about this notion
of selective security which says that
the adversary the guy
has to declare which attributes he's
planning to attack
right beforehand you know before he sees
big bang right i mean he says here it is
x star and then let's begin
okay why this is a little bit contrived
right i mean
uh why am i doing this one because
that's the only one and that's the only
thing i can get
and two because if you get it you can
pay a little bit in security and
actually get
adaptive security which is what i showed
in the previous slide right this is uh
by this uh you know you could call it a
technique a trick
a dirty trick it's called complexity
leveraging and you can
you can generically convert you have
this
transformation
no there is no transformation from
selective to adaptive there is no
several things actually so um we'll get
there
we'll get there so in the russell's
hierarchy of things
what is the relation between this thing
so this is uh there was a facebook
discussion at some point
about what to name these creatures um
and i think
uh one of the candidates was uh
was it ubercrypt or something like that
there is no these things have not been
named yet they've not been baptized yet
so if you want to go ahead
you know and uh really getting paid and
things like that we almost
like separated from each other i don't
know no no i don't know
so in some sense it's it's very hard to
talk about separations here right
because
you could these things play with
circuits that's their playground right
so these circuits could in fact be the
encryption circuit of the scheme itself
how do you right i mean i'm sure there's
a way to roll it out but
it's a very optimistic name
um okay so uh so we don't know where
these things land but clearly
these things imply public encryption and
cca encryption and so forth
yeah okay good excellent so this is what
i'm to talk about i'm going to talk
about selective security and like i said
you pay a little bit
do complexity leveraging you get
adaptive security okay that's
that's what that is all right so so
what's the what's the result
uh i'm gonna tell you about an attribute
based encryption for circuits
and the assumption is going to be the
sub-exponential learning with errors
assumption which you already
heard about and this again is related to
worst-case
shortest vector approximation in
lattices and so on and so forth right i
mean this is something you afford
yes the reason that sub exponential lw
is so that you can do complexity
leverage or is there another reason
there is another reason okay so the
reason will come in five seconds
approximately
five seconds you mean the approximation
not the hardness
yes yes i mean the i mean the
approximation factor that's the
exponential
good point thank you thank you
okay so these schemes are going to have
a short ciphertext what is short
yes bunny for the complexity everything
you need also how the site
not the de facto yes yes i mean
eventually when i get adaptive security
i need i need
i need hardness but uh for the selective
secure scheme i only need
yes indeed indeed
um good so so this theorem is for
selective
uh security right i mean
yes
good excellent so k is the number of
bits in the description of the
attributes
in the x exactly exactly so so the
cipher text what do they do they encrypt
an x send a message message forget it i
mean uh you know
whatever really what matters is the size
of the attributes
so what i'm saying is that uh the
ciphertext have size polynomial in the
size of the
attributes and the depth which is uh you
know and the maximum depth of the
circuits i can handle in this game
of p indeed indeed so i didn't put this
in
the size of the the circuit size of p
exactly
so ciphertext keys so really the the the
new thing here
which none of the other attribute based
encryption schemes that i know of
forget the things from i o okay so uh
you know
modulo i o right consider all the
attribute based encryption scheme
they they have the property that the
secret key for a predicate for a
policy for a circuit grows polynomially
with the size of circuit in fact it's
even it's
a little bit better it's the size of the
circuit the size of p times polynomial
in the security parameter
it makes sense right i mean i take a
circuit as input what am i going to do i
do something to each gate you know it's
it's gross polynomial right this scheme
has a property that the size of the
secret key is the size of the policy
circuit
period no times polynomial nothing
plus polynomial in the uh
in the attribute size and the input size
of the circuit and that
okay so as you grow the size of the
circuit these things are lower order
terms
so really you know it's a it's as small
as you can get in a sense
one bit per game exactly exactly
one bit per description uh length of the
circuit yeah
right so uh so that's what uh in fact
you know what
the secret key is in fact going to be
the description of the circuit
and a bunch of things so it is one bit
per
sort of description length
right so that's what the scheme is uh
and uh we'll we'll let's get into it
okay so so this is what i'm going to
construct the main idea
in the in the construction which is
probably even more important than uh
you know the things we get than the
attribute based encryption is this idea
of key homomorphism
right so chemomorphism you know this
idea has
come up in many places in various forms
various definitions
but here what i mean is the following
i'm going to encrypt i'm going to come
up with an encryption algorithm that
takes a public year master public key
attributes and a message i'm going to
somehow i'm going to tell you a way to
encrypt them
what i'm going to do when i decrypt when
i run the decryption algorithm
is the following i'm going to compute
homomorphically
on this ciphertext i'm not doing
anything to the message why because the
message stays the same it's either
output or it's not output right so
that's kind of the lower bit
forget about it but what i am going to
do is i am going to compute on the
master public key
and i'm going to compute on the
attributes and i'm going to do it
at the same time so it's it's like a
nice sort of tango
dance right i mean they go hand in hand
so in other words i convert i i will
come up with a way to convert
the ciphertext into an encryption under
a public key under a different public
key and this is a public key that
depends
on the circuit b and only on the circuit
not the attributes right you compute
compute compute you get something
and when i do this this process it also
turns out that it automatically computes
on the attributes
the same function right so it sort of
goes
hand in hand and this is what i get
that's the first step in decryption and
this is remember everyone can do it this
is a public process it's homomorphism
right anyone can do it
and then i'm going to say well let me
give you a secret key for this policy
right and once you put them together you
get the message
if this guy happens to be true zero
okay that's the decryption process is
going to be two step
one everyone can do this this
large computation this key homomorphic
computation
and then you know a little bit of
information helps you recover
actually the message conditioned on this
that's how it's going to work so really
there are three components to this
picture
one what is this chemomorphism and how
do i do it
right and how do i go from a public key
to another public
how do i change public keys two
how do i change ciphertex right i mean
this is this is just saying how do i go
from what is the transformation
that takes one public key to another
this one i actually
that's not good enough i want to take
ciphertext to ciphertext that's number
two
and three what is this magic secret key
that uh you know lets you decrypt uh
the end three pieces okay
and we'll do one one at a time and
yes this one and piece two piece one
says how do i compute on the public key
right you can think about it divorced
from everything else
how do i take public keys and generate
public keys
two how do i compute on ciphertext
encrypted using these publications
right and three well at the end you do
something
and you're done okay that's what i
wanted
good all right
okay so let me tell you what the keys
are what the public keys are
okay the master public key is going to
be a sequence of
matrices of lattices of matrices very
much the same as what zwika and
daniel talked about so these are
n by m matrices short fat matrices you
could think about them as a
lwe matrices if you're familiar with it
or generator matrices of a code if
that's more convenient to you so on and
so forth right short file matrices
and um how do i define this public key
how do i compute on these public keys
how do i compute on these matrices
well you've seen matrices today many
times
more than you might have wanted to okay
so
one as as cipher text for a homomorphic
encryption scheme
and two as commitments in daniel stock
and three as public keys also in daniel
stock right so matrices they're all the
same type of matrices
right and you operated on them and both
of these guys i don't know if
you noticed um both of these guys
operated on these matrices
and they did the same operation right
the homomorphic evaluation
was the same as the homomorphic
commitment evaluation and the same as a
homomorphic signature
evaluation in a sense uh and that is
that right so all i need to do is how to
how to
to tell you how to add and multiply
public keys
here's how you add what else are you
going to do here's how you multiply
which is essentially multiplying these
matrices except i'm going to do a bit
decomposition of one of these matrices
take the short matrix write the bits
then it becomes square i'm going to set
the parameter so that it becomes square
then i can multiply that's it right
that's that's that
so these guys look like fhe
cipher attacks and and commitments
homomorphic commitments
and you know we'll see in the rest of
the talk that they don't just
look like these things they act like
these things we'll see there's a very
deep connection between
what happens here and what happened in
the last two talks we'll see
okay but this is the way you compute on
public keys in any case
you add public keys and you multiply
except you do this uh
you know bit decomposition to one of the
uh keys
so this is as you can see it's a it's a
a little bit looks a little bit ugly for
a couple of reasons one there's a minus
i did it for my convenience and two
there is this bit decomposition that you
do right you don't just multiply these
matrices you do a bit decomposition
that's the same reason why the bid
decomposition came up in
zwika and daniel's talk okay in any case
here's how you operate on public keys
period
okay so this is the same as the same
operation as a
ciphertext commitments uh signatures so
forth
two how do i operate on cipher text
right which match this evolution of the
public key
ah before that i have to tell you what a
ciphertext is right
so what is the ciphertext the ciphertext
is essentially
just a sequence of lwe samples relative
to these matrices in other words
i pick a random s the encryption
algorithm tosses coins it picks this
s it computes s times
a so think of s as
s is an n dimensional lwe secret you
multiply it with a
so you expand it and then you add a
little bit of error to each coordinate
right so that's how you generate lwe
samples and that's uh
that's what that is okay
had fun with one matrix let's keep going
right
and so on and so forth so each
i'm going to have k additional
ciphertext each one
corresponds to a bit of the attribute x1
up to xk
are the attribute vector written down as
bits
and ah these guys are essentially lwe
samples
relative to these matrices right a i
plus x i times g g is this gadget matrix
from uh which is essentially a
just a moment steve um which is
essentially a sequence of uh
powers of two so forth if you remember
it that's good
if you don't that's okay that's fine too
uh if x is zero i'll have uh just a i
here
right it's a i plus x i g so if x is
there
you have the attribute or zero no so for
a moment you should think about it this
way right
you have an attribute vector you just
write down the bit string
right there is a circuit that computes
on it just write down the bit string
that describes the attribute somewhere
anywhere you want right so i mean
doesn't have to be yes or no
it could be ip less than something so
how do you write to me
good so this is it this is the
encryption
right so it has one piece for every bit
of the attribute
vector the uh the attribute
and that's that okay where does the
message come in ah
excellent it's a great point i like the
message
i love the message but i don't love it
so much as to put it in this slide in
fact
what i'm going to do is i'm i'm going to
ignore the message
completely and if you want to think
about it think about it as
you know where does the message come in
i'm going to take the hardcore bit of
the
s and exotic with the message that's one
way to do it there are more lattice
friendly ways of doing it but
lower bits so you know why why do i not
care about the message the same reason
you don't care about the message in
public encryption schemes you only care
about the cam
key right in a sense
okay so the message doesn't come in
doesn't matter okay
okay so now i have to show you number
two which is how do you
evolve cipher attacks right so so i have
this cipher ciphertext
looks scary but it's really you know
this this is what it is
right each public key corresponds to a
bit of the attribute you add it to x1
xig and take the lwe sample relative to
it that's it
okay so now i have to yes shaffy
polynomial in x but it's not out of the
question that would be linear
right right now yeah it's it's actually
linear in x
right i mean it's one for every bit of x
so it's
size of x times polynomial in the
security parameter
right that's what i'm saying oh you
could make it even shorter yeah that's
just totally totally
yeah totally in fact we know how to do
it from multi-linear
maps but uh okay
you know at the beginning you said you
were going to work in a setting where
the attributes are public
yes ah
good good good good so so the reason i'm
encrypting the attributes is not so much
to hide them
but to enforce computation enforce
correct computation so in other words
um we'll see we'll see in a minute so
i i'm not going to even try to hide the
attributes
but i want to ensure that you get the
message at the end which i which i
didn't write down
the message is really the hardcore bit
of the s let's say right the gold
reclive in hardcore bfs
you should get it only if you uh
you know your computation lands up in a
certain state that's
i want correctness i want to ensure
correctness soundness as opposed to
privacy
we'll hopefully see that uh in a in a
bit okay
so in case this is the uh ciphertext and
i want
to get to this state right i want to
evolve the public key
the public key used to be a concatenated
with a1 up to ak this is a long public
key
and eventually i want to do something
that lands me
at this ciphertext which is really an
lwe sequence of lwe samples
relative to this matrix a sub p and what
is a sub yes
where to the left of it
no this is this goes here this goes here
the rest of it i'm going to carry it
right i mean i'm going to mix and match
it and what is this asap
it's really uh this asap
right what you what you did computations
on and you landed up at that asap is
what i want to land up at
okay so that's the question really so so
in some sense i don't have these
a i plus x i g and so forth i only have
a linear function of this a i
plus x a noisy linear function and i
want to somehow evolve this noisy linear
function
at the end i should get another noisy
linear function of the same s
right how do i do that how do i do that
right
so the main sort of thing here
is linearity and the main thing in all
these encryption schemes
is the fact that even though you try to
destroy linearity by adding noise
there still remains enough that you can
do wonderful things with it
for this talk for the next one no right
or the next one no so i don't think of
that as an inherent
difficulty
good so how do i operate on on
ciphertext um
good so um
adding is adding right adding ciphertext
you have
two linear functions right uh of the
same s
and i want to compute the sum linear
function
the sum of these guys and i just add
them so i'm not
writing so this is not the ciphertext
the ciphertext has a noise here
but never mind okay let's work without
noise and see what happens
okay so i'm just going to add them and
this has the property that this is s
transpose this is the linear function
this is the linear function indexed by s
on the public key which is the sum of
the two public keys
and by the way that's how we defined
evolution of public keys you know once
the two public is passed through an
audition gate they sum they add together
plus
the the attributes also add together
all right so remember what i said this
tango dance right i mean like you know
the
the public keys evolve and the
attributes evolve
the same way right that's that's what
happens
addition is really easy straight forward
now i want to do multiplication and once
i do it i'm done
right and the point is i want to
maintain this invariant that at
every wire i have s transpose times the
public key for that wire which we
defined before
plus the value the attribute value on
that wire times g
that's what i want okay so let's uh
let's work backwards okay this is this
is going to be a little bit of algebra
but uh bear with me uh you know it feels
like a
it feels like a rabbit out of the hat
that's how i feel also
um so let's uh let's go let's let's
let's see what uh how we can get there
okay so this is what i want this is the
end result i want
and so what is this right so what is
this i defined the public key on that
wire
to be a u times g inverse of a b with a
minus sign on it that's how i defined
the public key for that wire and the
value on this wire is clearly
it's a multiplication gate so you
multiply the two guys right that's that
okay so i want to get here starting from
these two guys
right so what's the first thing to do i
take the first ciphertext
this guy and multiply it with g inverse
of a b
right that's the first thing to do and
that actually gives me what i want here
i get s transpose a u times g inverse of
e b that's that
right but you know with everything good
comes
something bad right so i also get this
other creature
which i don't want so what do i get
i get let me go back and forth a little
bit
so the other thing i get is x u times g
times g inverse
which is identity function so x u times
av
is the other thing i get which i don't
want because i
doesn't look like this i don't want it
right but then i didn't use the other
ciphertext
right think about it
so i use it okay so i take the other
ciphertext multiplied with x sub u
this is where i use the fact that uh i
use the knowledge of
the attribute this is the only place i
use the knowledge of the attributes
right so i do x u times this and that
voila
it cancels out so what do i get i get x
u times a v here
i have a minus x u times a v here
cancels out vola you get
the answer okay thanks for your time
this is a little bit out of the hat i uh
i apologize but uh
i am using i am i'm i'm uh to cancel out
this rogue term i am using i'm going to
take
one of the ciphertext which has an av in
it and i'm going to multiply it with x2x
use the attribute
right that i'm interpreting so
so you know xu i know xu so so
that's a good point so so uh what money
is asking i think
if i understand right there's uh two
things to say right i mean
it could be that the that the actual
decryption algorithm doesn't have to
know xu
but still somehow xu is revealed that's
not the case
even the actual decryption algorithm has
to know xu to work
the the x to work right so really very
crucially public attributes
one but if you think about sort of when
you go down the circuit you need to know
everything really
i mean except yes
there is you could define an
intermediate creature indeed indeed
indeed indeed indeed in the innes
indeed in a sense that sort of captures
the difficulty of uh
going beyond uh beyond
okay so uh so just to answer your
beginnings question so
it is true that in general you need to
know all the attributes but uh
hotek is going to use this fact that
here you only need to know
one of the halves not both very
crucially
and that is that is indeed what is going
to let him move beyond
public attributes one step okay so we'll
get there
but slow okay so things cancel out
nice um and now the point is this right
so now we have
a way public way to take an encryption
of these
attributes public attributes
and convert it into an encryption under
a different public key under under this
asap
but but it's all encrypted right i mean
so so so so together with this
comes the hardcore bit of exhaust with
the message
and i actually want to let someone you
know decrypt it and get
s and decrypt this uh this thing so what
do i do
my predicate secret key which we still
haven't defined i'd have to use it of
course
is the trapdoor for this matrix
is the information that lets you take
s transpose aap
and derive and invert it in the sense
reconstruct
s from it that is what the trapdoor lets
you do you don't have to know what the
trapdoor is
but here is what the trapdoor lets you
do right it lets you
solve lwe it lets you solve lwe relative
to this matrix
and now think about it if the predicate
on x evaluated to true that is
at least zero right
then this evolution gave you a cipher
text relative to this matrix s transpose
aap
and voila the trapdoor lets you uh
decrypt
right so to answer lucas question you
know even though the attributes are
public
what what's happening here is i'm tying
the computation
of the predicate on the public keys to
the computation
on the attributes so when i reach this
point
i cannot possibly get a sub b so i have
to get a sub p because i want to use
this trap door to decrypt
but i cannot get it together with
something else
1 minus b x let's say that cannot happen
clearly if that happens i violate
security so i mean if
my scheme is correct that cannot happen
but it cannot happen for a fundamental
reason right because the way i evolved
cipher text in public keys
i it went hand in hand whatever you did
on the attributes also happened on the
on the
predicates on the public keys right
that's the problem
okay so in case this is uh this is what
it is don't really have to know the
details it's a trapdoor that's that
okay good
okay good so so what's the scheme
let's uh big picture right the public
keys are a sequence of
matrices lwe matrices um
uh this is the encryption and anna
here is uh i know it's not here but anna
uh here is the hardcore bit plus the
message
uh that's the encryption it's a real
encryption of the message the secret key
is a trapdoor for this matrix and you
can compute
you decrypt in two steps one you start
from the ciphertext and you compute
s transpose aap then you use the
ciphertext you use the secret key to
divine the s that's it right
so it has this nice feature that most of
the computation in the decryption
anyone can do it's a sort of public uh
anyone can do it
and at the end you just flip the switch
and you get the answer
okay this you need to make
why do i need the matrix a good um you
haven't seen it so far
um but i have one thing i haven't told
you i told you a lot of things right
one thing i haven't told you is how do i
generate the trap door
for this matrix a and a sub p right i
mean
someone has to be able to do it i mean i
can do it exponential time i suppose but
uh
someone with knowledge of the master
trapdoor has to be able to do it
so if i didn't have that a i don't know
what the master trap door is that would
let me to do these things
so we'll we'll we'll get there in a
minute
okay but in any case this is the scheme
right so
in fact let's get there right now right
how do you
i'm going to tell you the idea behind
the uh the security proof and it really
is going to be one slide
right it's a clean one slide proof
and before that uh let me tell you how
to actually generate
trap doors right how how does the honest
secret key generation algorithm work the
reason i'm telling you this now
is because there's going to be another
key generation algorithm
which i'm not going to use in the scheme
but i'm only going to use it in the
proof
and they're going to be
indistinguishable they're going to do
indistinguishable things okay so
here is how i generate a trapdoor for
for the matrix a sub p
and what is a trapdoor okay so let's uh
it's uh let's back up is a trapdoor
is a short vector uh t
drop door is a short vector t
such that a a sub p
times t is 0 mod q
in fact you need many short vectors
linearly independent short vectors but
never mind just one is uh
good enough for us okay so in other
words it's a vector in the terminal of
this matrix
a sub p which is short
enormous small right and that's what i
want to generate
and here is the first trick that uh that
lets you do this
this is what it says says the following
you can
if you if i give you the trap door for a
that's the same a
up there you can generate
the trap door this this vector
for any a concatenated with b you pick
your b
concatenate you can do it right
so in particular that means that no
matter what this policy circuit is
no matter how you evolve and compute
this a sub p
you can generate the secret key for it
just knowing the trap door for a
that's it right that's the chkp that's a
gush of fine skill spiker trick
beautiful idea and we'll see a short
roof
in a minute
turns out that you know as you can
imagine
things are different things look
different in the security proof because
you know if the reduction knew the
trapdoor for a there is nothing for it
to solve
right so we're going to use a different
sort of way to generate
generate trapdoors by the way the
reduction also needs to generate secret
keys
right i mean uh you know the guy comes
and asks me give me a secret key for
this circuit p
what am i going to do i have to generate
secret keys that's going to happen in a
different way
and indeed it's going to happen in an
indistinguishable way right i mean these
two guys are going to
produce indistinguishable trapdoors
and the way this works is this is the
agarwal banay bayan
trick and what this says is the
following
assume that you know i have a
concatenated with some matrix b
right and moreover that this matrix b
has a special form
right then it looks like a times r where
r is a short matrix r is a matrix of
small entries right so it's a small
linear transformation of a
plus g it's a strange uh strange form
but suppose it looks like that
and i know this r and the trapdoor for g
i can generate something i can generate
a sort of a
trapdoor vector for aap which looks
exactly
like statistically like what happens
here
okay so that's what uh that's what i can
do
me see okay
um let me just tell you how um
you know what let me just tell you how
this works
how chkp works and
the other trick is an exercise it's an
easy exercise
okay so so what do what do i want i have
the trapdoor for a
right i mean what is the trouble for a
let me do
it lets me find short solutions to
linear equations
okay so so a times some t
equals something else you can find a
short t
that solves this equation that's what a
trout does lets you do
and what i want to do is i want to solve
this system of equations right i mean
a and b are given to me and c is also
given to me they're vectors these two
are matrices this is a vector
and i want to find the short t1
concatenate t2 so t1 and t2 are they
one is on top of the other right such
that this is true
right how do i do it so i only have the
trot door for a
i only know how to solve linear
equations of the form
a times some unknown equals something
and find a short solution in these
unknowns that's all i know how to do
and now you give me this b what in the
world am i supposed to do
right any ideas
d2 at random indeed indeed okay good
you know should give harder questions it
seems um
so picky two are random right because b
is not something that you don't have
control over so just pick t2 at random
and now you only have to solve this
equation
right c minus this this guy is a times t
1
plus b times t 2 because this guy
looks like this and this i can solve
using the trouble for a
that's it and in fact you can even
generate the correctly distributed
solutions so on and so forth right
this is what it is
very simple right let me actually tell
you what this what this thing is
so here i don't have the trapdoor for a
i don't have the chapter for what
whatever is here on the right hand side
right but i have this strange
information i know what r is i know what
g
is i know how to write the right hand
side as a times r plus g
bizarre right now i want to solve now i
want to find solutions to this equation
how do i do it okay
well this is a harder question maybe i
should have quizzed you on this
okay so the first thing to observe is
that this
this r actually gives me a linear a
short linear transformation
that takes this matrix to the g matrix
the g matrix is nice it's this
powers of two matrix you know that rotor
in fact not just you
everyone in the world knows a trapdoor
and so forth right so i can do a linear
transformation which is really minus
r a times minus r plus this guy truly g
right so that that you know that's
that's a that's a good thing
to happen so now how are you going to
solve uh this equation
well i know how to solve one of these i
know how to solve find t such that g
times t equals u because i know the
tread door for g
right g is this gadget matrix the same
thing that you saw all over and you have
trapdoors for it everyone knows that
outdoor you can solve it
sorry good
see sorry good one thank you
so the point is you don't know how to
solve this equation right
but you know how to you know start with
what you know how to solve
right you know how to solve g times t
equals c this is c just kind of
tilt your head and uh look at it you
know it'll be it'll be fine
um and the claim is that that actually
gives you a solution to the original
linear equation just because
you know a transformation that you know
a linear transformation that maps one to
the other
so in fact this matrix r concatenate i
times t transpose times t is a solution
to the linear equation that you wanted
so the idea is that
you don't need to have a trapdoor for a
matrix you only need to
know how to transform this matrix
linearly transform this matrix
to another one for which you know the
top dot that's good enough
that's already using the fact that the r
is short because i wanted
short solutions right i wanted small
solutions so my final solution is going
to be
this guy times t so t small and yeah
good beautiful tricks
no and we're not going to get there
there is a way to make it
make everything correct it's a an
epsilon more than this but it's an
epsilon less from hortex time so
let me good okay security proof
should i do it or where is her deck okay
he's looking at me like he's gonna
like uh you know kill me so uh no
security proof and in fact hotek will do
the security proof for this
and better so let's uh
you have to do it now
okay okay
it pains me to not do it but that's okay
um okay so so this same idea comes up in
many different places this work with
zvika on
constrained pseudorandom functions for
all circuits uses essentially
very very similar ideas
open questions adaptive security i don't
know how to get it other than using
complexity leveraging
um can i do remove this dependence on
the dap so why did this depth thing come
in
because when i computed on these
ciphertexts
i ignored the noise but i cannot i mean
i really have to account for how much it
increases and that
uh contributes to sort of a bound on the
depth and i don't know how to bootstrap
it
the point is if you move to a stronger
object a private uh attribute object
called functional encryption
which will tell you what you can
bootstrap
you can do adapter security generically
you can bootstrap generically i mean
everything becomes so much nicer and and
simpler so without further ado